-I've been very excited
to see you.
I love seeing you.
-I love seeing you, too.
-Yeah, I -- I want to get into
your two movies.
They're giant movies.
You're -- You're the --
You're the Hollywood
"it girl" right now.
-Am I?
-Yeah, I said so.
-That's nice to say.
-I want to ask you a question.
This is serious.
-[ Somber voice] Okay.
What is it, Jimmy?
-I heard --
[ Laughter ]
-Yes?
-I heard that you like --
I heard that you like
to crash weddings,
and I just think
that's interesting.
-Oh, well --
That is interesting.
[ Laughter ]
It's interesting you say that.
I did that once.
[ Laughter ]
-But you don't -- like, that's
not a thing that you do?
-Well, a friend of mine,
we were in the same place.
And I was, like -- I was
in Italy with my sisters.
And in Italy, they have --
they have a lot of wine there.
[ Laughter ]
And...
-So that was your invite
right there, huh?
-So that -- they --
my friend was at this wedding.
And he's like, "Just come.
It's a really big wedding.
No one will know."
And then, all of a sudden,
I'm just making eye contact
with the bride
as she's being
bounced in a chair.
[ Laughter ]
And she was like...
-Yeah.
-"What?"
-That's pretty fun.
-"Why is she here?"
-That's cool, though.
"Dakota Johnson's
at my wedding."
-I'm a nice person to --
[ Laughter ]
-I know you are!
Yeah.
But I mean -- But so that's --
I'm sorry, I thought that was
the story, that you crash
weddings, you crash parties.
-No. Well, like, the other night
in here, actually,
I was just at dinner
with friends and they were like,
"We're going to a birthday party
at Electric Lady."
So I went to that.
-And you --
you weren't really
invited to that, either?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No, I wasn't.
But it actually
wasn't even a birthday party.
It was a staff party.
[ Laughter ]
-That's even crazier.
But then -- But then --
-Yeah.
-So maybe you do --
-They were really like,
"What are you doing here?"
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe you do crash things
and you don't think about it.
Is there any other scam?
[ Laughter ]
-Was I invited to this show?
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Laughter ]
You were --
You are always invited
to this show.
We love you.
-Thanks.
-I want to talk about --
You have two movies.
Two big movies.
Let's get right to it.
"Persuasion" is coming out
July 15th, on Netflix.
It's a Jane Austen adaptation.
You're wearing gorgeous dresses,
running around -- yep.
I love Jane Austen.
-Me too.
-[ British accent ]
I really liked it because
I do, um...
-Accents.
-Yeah, I do.
How'd you know?
-That's really good, yeah.
-Is it?
Is it, though?
Is it -- Is it good?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
-Is it all right?
-Not really.
-Yeah, not really.
-No.
-I do accents
every now and then.
I can do a different one.
And I'm just saying,
I could audition.
I could be in the next movie
that you want to be in."
-[ Laughing ] Are you okay?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
That's -- That's the reaction
I want from people --
"Are you okay?"
-Yeah.
-He's transformed.
-Are you great -- but are you
good with accents?
Do you love doing them?
-I love doing them.
I had an amazing vocal coach
for "Persuasion," though.
Jill McCullough.
And then, her assistant,
Helen Simmons,
was on set with me.
-Yeah.
-And we would do, like,
crazy warm-ups in the mornings
at like 5:00 in the morning.
-Whoa.
-Which would be hard-core.
So we'd make them
really, really naughty.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
Okay. Just to try
and keep it interesting
at 5:00 in the morning?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What else are you gonna do
except say a bunch of, like,
really gnarly words.
-Is there any ones you can say
on television?
-Yeah.
One of them was like,
"Look at the lovely lemons
in the lounge."
-Wow.
[ British accent ]
Look -- Look at the --
[ Laughter ]
Hey! Oi!
Look at the lovely lemons
on the lounge.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I'm telling you, I'm available.
-Or like, "Please put the tiny
cup on the kitchen top."
-Please put a cup on the tea --
on the top.
[ Laughter ]
Please put a cup --
Hey, put a cup on the tea!
Put a --
-It's Mick Jagger.
-[ Normal voice ]
Mick Jagger, yeah.
I'm just saying I can do that.
If you need that in your film,
you know --
-That's what I need.
-You know who to call.
I'm your guy.
But, congrats.
Let's talk about
"Cha Cha Real Smooth."
-Yes.
-I love -- I love the title.
-You got it right.
-Of course.
-Yeah.
-"Cha Cha Real Smooth."
I know that jam. It's in
theaters and on Apple TV+.
It's -- You're getting
rave reviews for this.
How do we set this up?
-This is my company, TeaTime's,
first movie that we made.
We developed it from an idea
that the director,
Cooper Raiff, brought to us.
It's about a young man
who leaves college
and doesn't have a job,
doesn't really know what to do
with himself,
and he becomes a party starter
at bar mitzvahs
and bat mitzvahs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And he meets a young mother
of -- of, like, a 14-year-old
autistic girl
and falls in love with her.
-Yeah.
It's -- It's a sweet story.
And "Cha Cha Real Smooth,"
why is that the title?
Just 'cause --
-Well, you know,
in the "Cha-Cha Slide"...
-Yeah.
-...the part of the song --
This --
Cooper came up with this,
and it's annoying
because it's really good.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah.
-You wanted credit for it?
-Yeah.
I'm on TV right now,
so I'm gonna take credit for it.
-Yeah.
-He said -- No, I say,
it's the part of the song
where you do your own dance.
-Oh, yeah.
Because he tells you the --
-"Cha-Cha now, y'all."
-Yeah.
-And then
you do your own boogie.
-Yeah, so this is his part
of his life where he's like,
"This is the part
where I do my own thing."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's a good title.
I will say, congrats.
It won the
Audience Award at Sundance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it was one of
the biggest sellers
out of Sundance.
Big hit.
-Yeah.
-Big, successful.
Congratulations.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dakota Johnson
in "Cha Cha Real Smooth."
Take a look at this.
-On the Earth, we all have,
like, a ton of soul mates.
And I think for you, maybe,
it's like a special case
where you only have a few...
-[ Chuckles ]
...who, like, could be and
really are your soul mates.
But most of the people in the
world aren't your soul mates.
-How many soul mates?
-For you?
Like, four.
-Four?
-Yeah, four soul mates.
-I probably
haven't met any of them.
-No, you have.
God puts them, like,
on your path so you'll cross.
-How many do you have?
-Like 1,200.
-[ Laughs ]
-Have you met any?
-Yes.
Domino, domino, domino.
-[ Gasps ]
[ Crashing, body thuds ]
Oh, my God. That's a ton
of blood right away.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, my God. That's a ton
of blood right away."
Dakota Johnson, everybody!
"Cha Cha Real Smooth"
is in theaters
and on Apple TV+ this Friday.
Dakota and I are doing
"Mad Lib Karaoke"
when we come back.
Stick around.